I will say I can't like distinguish
between the I'm eating pizza Hayes and
I'm getting a little drunk Hayes I mean
I think pizza and booze are one of the
great marriages of our time jay-z and
Beyonce they're like pizza and alcohol I
don't know about having them together
it's more efficient
sounds pretty disgusting lois lane's
well I'm down to try it see they're
gonna be very good or disgusting tastes
fine fish like pizza we're gonna get
drunk taste it now and I taste like
fairly needs though I have no problem
this business pizzas good
so if I get just a saucy little lick
right there I'm probably really taste
the booze
since the I see little link and then did
the weirdest look I've ever seen it's
like the first bite you're like oh it's
pizza and then you can taste this like
bitterness she's loving it like a good
Cabernet you just dump your piece dock
your pizza in it and you did like that's
promising
those are drinking from now on I'm not
tasting it at all my standards are
pretty low to be quite honest like I do
not have five sharing standards
did you hear me just mumble my words due
to my drunk I left you individually I'll
give you individual Ian now that you've
done this we can't undo that it's it's
all hot in here so what through this top
someone should take my phone oh man I'm
gonna text everybody if you hadn't told
me there was alcohol in that pizza I
would have eaten the whole slice and not
thinking I had consumed any alcohol I'm
gonna just drink this chawl i ee i oh my
god i think it could be a thing since
jared didn't taste the alcohol that
there's also a lot of other people that
won't if someone out there could find a
way to make this not taste like vodka in
it that's one of my favorite ways to
consume alcohol if you want to slow down
getting drunk you should be a lot of
bread this is good for that they're both
beautiful in their own right you don't
need to be me they don't mean to come
together it's going worse